very 2016 hi guys welcome to her diary
if you do not know for there you can
look back in my weekend blog for curly
I'm in the airport at JFK in New York
City Brooklyn crap but I didn't start my
week here krinklesac had always started
with me slump very happy 29th really in
a car headed from Philadelphia to New
York City I came home for the holidays
look who's here oh yes we're doing kiss
oh my gosh I can't tell me my guns gonna
do okay I'm happy yeah well not good
morning oh my god oh this is my mother's
beautiful tablescape the morning after
christmas are you so proud bill is
making eggs and what's under here not
have to touch this yes people don't know
what yeah tell me if you know what it is
it's scrapple grapple if you don't know
it's basically all scraps of meat push
together into a new meat and it is
delicious basically just a block of
sodium for your body and we love it
right Tim oh yeah sodium is cool
good morning Tim good morning grace how
was your Christmas
oh it was great I got everything I
wanted so lucky thing yeah it's like
it's kinda like spam yeah just salt
diversion yeah could I like spam no no
that's why much traffic huh yeah got to
see a lot of New Jersey we went to the
beach down by where my dad lives for the
shore okay so I got my nephew a
hoverboard for Christmas and my stepmom
is trying it for the first time my
stepmom is my brother that's my other
brother that's my nephew
that's Chester with my uncle Ted and
this is my dad you're doing it marine
someone loves wah wah
and we went to Philadelphia some
touristy Philadelphia things we're in
Philly so we have to do this whoa it's
the rocky stairs and it's raining okay
ready go ahead you're doing it now I'm
doing it this way
nature's tears yeah and we went to the
airport
last night to try and fly back to Los
Angeles and uh didn't happen because of
inclement weather here's a dramatization
of the situation the airport that I
didn't film because I was such in a bad
mood I was having a real rough time with
it
there's a dramatization what's happening
why can't we leave no one is telling us
anything
hmm it was a great situation but now at
home because our plans have gotten
slightly deterred we have taken a
different turn we're renting a car going
to New York City and see what happens so
let's have an adventure
beautiful Philadelphia beautiful
Philadelphia so we made it to New York
City for New Year's I guess I guess
we're here for New Year's yesterday
didn't do very much but ate this
delicious food whoa
and today haven't done very much oh I
got a new iPhone mine current one I
broke it and that's an excuse to get the
new phone but I got the bigger one
because I just want my head to feel tiny
one day but I wanted to show you guys
somehow we got an amazing amazing room
in this hotel that we booked last minute
on the drive up to New York I want you
guys to see this view what what hello
lower Manhattan you look great this is
so crazy look at that you know there's
always people having some of the
greatest moments in the worst moments of
their lives right now then we're out
there someone is being proposed to right
now and somewhere out there someone is
praying to a god about their butthole
Wow life is beautiful
so it's Wednesday night in about three
hours ago we were gonna go see Creed
moving out the band who knows which is
better but this person had lung issues
and still are not resolved we don't
think it's anything hugely serious but
we've been here three hours and much
blood has been taken plays Liam Neeson
because his blood has been taken
what I did extra you look great
oh yeah look we're gonna find out
hopefully to be continued things that
escalated still it's 2:30 a.m.
we are back in hotel room waiting on
room service this one has not been
completely diagnosed all of the tests
were negative they're still painted
pending in Minden and in your lung but
they think he is okay to leave the
hospital here's hoping his body doesn't
completely explode or quit they just
have a mr. great pain right about here
that won't go away maybe you're pregnant
in your ribs you know that's how Adam
and Eve were born ah beautiful sound -
wake up - good morning New York City
happy 2016
it is officially January 1st and I'm
bringing 2016 in like a lion yep how did
I spend New Year's in this hotel room
overlooking New York City
yes sir
like yeah yeah do you like Nick John
Martin watch making vision boards and
goal lists for 2016 because I'm prepared
app now we're at it to the airport to go
back to Los Angeles to get a princess
monster that's waiting for me
in Los Angeles okay and now we're going
back to Los Angeles to celebrate the
beginning 2016 with an animal covered in
fur Polo Club and aggression
aggressively I hope you had a wonderful
wonderful day let me know what you did
because I care
2016 I don't know someone did come in
after they saved my body hmm told me
that everything's gonna be for me right
and this time I told you everything was
going to be fine put this pretty pretty
dress on